here are some celebs who made the choice
to americanize their birth names forgive
me if I mispronounced this but Mindy
Kaling was born Vera Mindy and she said
that she shortened her last name because
MC's a comedy shows kept butchering it
and as for her first name she said that
she's actually never been called Vera by
her family they always called her Mindy
and they chose that name because they
thought it was a cute American name and
they were moving to America Michelle yo
was born yochu Kang in Malaysia so her
first name is Ashley Chu Kang because
Malaysian names follow Eastern order so
the surname comes first but she started
her acting career in Hong Kong and the
studio she was working with wanted to
make her more marketable to Western
audiences so they started crediting her
as Michelle Khan when she did debut in
the west with the James Bond movie
Tomorrow Never Dies that's when she
changed her stage name to Michelle yo
Bruno Mars was born Peter Gene Hernandez
in Hawaii when he was two years old his
dad started calling him Bruno after a
professional wrestler and he came up
with a stage name Mars because he was in
the studio joking and he kept telling
people that he was out of this world